hey Luke here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today my boys really
really wanted to fly kites with their
Grandma and Grandpa however it is as
calm as calm can be there's no wind so
we're gonna try we're gonna try to make
this happen
[Music]
all right let's do this here you guys
ready to get some wind okay we're gonna
be flying a kite eventually the bridge
will be a problem yes
you ready to play a kite you ready to
fly a kite
all right we got wet a little millennial
Falken and uh ly next wing in an unusual
turn of events I'm the one who went his
pants in this group
a little problem launching the boat
[Music]
[Applause]
I clipped it to the wrong part
oh I like that having cash in it
[Music]
why are you kind yeah let go hang on
Edina whose idea this was yeah that's
right it was Tommy's idea Tommy said we
should fly kites from the boat
oh well that was close
very close
I think that's the only power lines over
the roof over the river so I
alright grandpa go go go
they did go you doing a good job buddy
okay
there's less as we could go
[Music]
yeah no fancy don't got my
I hate I don't know how to put this
gently but a very large fastest
[Music]
you shot down Aegis starship
'sheriff way to the
[Music]
listen and beg for mercy
love please Mini's my bike
[Music]
you're about
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh Tommy Tommy you got your Mack string
out man
he spooled yeah
Becca will you drive the boat
[Music]
we go
I gotta tell you that works fabulously
dad every kind should be on a fishing
rod I mean except the one pom easel
they said the one tommy's hold which
will go down in flames
we're probably the only family flying
kites by moonlight on a winless day
well thanks for watching we hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor boy's
YouTube channel don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
week